this is a story I love and there are
moments when I'm sorry it never happened
again it only happened to me once I was
in my 30s I remember actually I was
reading svevo it was you know the
confessions of Zeno that's actually a
new translation but I was reading the
old one and I looked I was lying in bed
and I looked down at the floor and there
was a little pink man and a pink ox
about this tall moving and you don't
beautifully articulated so lovely and
they gave me a very good feeling I had
no fear no distress just a feeling of
fascination friendliness and pleasure
and I watched them for a while without
saying to myself I did not say you're
having an hallucination I didn't say it
I just looked at them and then they
disappeared this elucidation was
followed by a migraine and I didn't know
at the time I had no idea it they too
have a name it's called lilliputian
hallucinations it is associated with
migraine but other people you know
sometimes stroke people of had stroke
could also have these visual
hallucinations
it may have been epileptics but i think
again it's always so complicated in
medicine to draw a line between normal
experience and what's pathological I
mean this is this is not so easy to do
so for example it does seem that
something like auditory hallucinations
I've had it
a number of times the only time I really
have it now is when I'm dropping off to
sleep I will often hear voices men's
voices women's voices usually short
sentences very hard for me to remember
what they said in the morning in Nabokov
speak memory he has a wonderful little
passage about exactly that both his
hypnagogic hallucinations of a visual
kind before he's going to sleep and
hearing voices it's a beautifully
written little passage and speak memory
you know Nabokov was clearly not mad I
don't feel mad and many people in
there's certain studies that have been
done that many many people at one time
or another of experienced auditory
hallucinations it becomes part of a
pathology I think when for example in
schizophrenia people have schizophrenia
are often tormented by voices talking
all the time and jabbering away telling
them to do terrible things that becomes
a curse and also in schizophrenia
usually the presence of the voices are
explained in a delusional way you know
that the famous like CIA has planted
things in your brain or whatever this is
very common
whereas when I've had auto Tory
hallucinations I always thought I was
having out of translation I mean once I
mistook the voice of a friend for a real
experience you know that he was actually
calling me but but otherwise I haven't
so there are normal variants of
experiences that are often regarded as
as pathological such as hearing voices
or hallucinations